have you ever wondered what it's like to
be a snake milker
or a stunt person well then you're going
to want to check out a new show we're
testing
called odd jobs where we take you
through the craziest
quirkiest and most dangerous jobs in the
world check it out
[Music]
it starts with one bite then
100 soon 1 000.
now a swarm of one million blood-sucking
mosquitoes descends upon you
why is your blood their favorite snack
what would happen to your body if they
bit you
again and again and
could they eventually suck you
completely dry
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you were bitten by one million
mosquitoes
if you've ever been in tall grassy areas
or
near standing water you've experienced
the relentless buzzing and biting of
mosquitoes
but you might not know that there are
3 500 species of them and
only a couple hundred drink human blood
only the female mosquitoes bite that's
because
they need a tasty blood meal before they
can lay their eggs
mosquitoes are surprisingly picky too
they prefer men pregnant women and
people who are overweight but
perhaps their favorite victims are
people of a certain blood type
mosquitoes are almost twice as likely to
land on someone with
type o blood so if you fit that criteria
congratulations one million tiny insects
could be dining on you
tonight when the first mosquito lands
and takes a bite
you likely wouldn't feel a thing that's
because
her proboscis is very sharp and thin
and left alone she would feed on you
until she's full an asian tiger mosquito
for example would drink
approximately 0.005 milliliters of blood
that's the volume of a single mustard
seed
what you would notice is the itchy red
swelling
around the bite otherwise known as
skeeter syndrome
this is your body's allergic response to
an
anticoagulant in the mosquito's saliva
it prevents your blood from clotting so
the mosquito can get
every last drop if you were
unlucky you could have other allergic
reactions like
lesions bruises or swelling in the
throat
a handful of bites doesn't sound too bad
but
how about ninety 000 well
at this point you would lose close to
half a liter of blood
if you're an avid blood donor you're
used to this
though you would have a headache and
feel dizzy
nauseous and physically weak
you have about 1.75 square
meters of skin and taking on 90
000 mosquito bites would be a lot
you'd be bitten over five times for
every square centimeter of your body
and that includes your more delicate
areas
if you know what i mean and your
nightmare wouldn't
end there if 220 000 mosquitoes bit you
that would be about 13 bytes per square
centimeter
and you would lose 20 percent of your
blood
now your body would go into hypovolemic
shock
you would have major organ failure as
your heart
loses the pressure needed to circulate
your blood
you would become pale confused and weak
you could even slip into a coma now
if one million mosquitoes bit you
all five and a half liters of blood
would be drained from your body
each square centimeter of your skin
would be bitten
over 62 times that
means you would be a raw bloody
dead mess
so listen if you see a million
mosquitoes flying toward you
you should run but what about 1 million
other insects like ticks
well that's a story for another
what if
you